foreign
[Music]
welcome to Tech news briefing it's
Wednesday May 31st I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal artificial
intelligence is having a moment now but
in 1993 one of the companies that's key
to the growth of AI was just an idea
being developed over a meal at the diner
chain Denny's today our semiconductors
reporter ASA Fitch will join us to
explain how the chipmaker Nvidia which
reached the one trillion dollar
valuation this week became so essential
to the AI boom
[Music]
but first an Extinction event as great
as pandemics and nuclear war that's the
threat Tech Executives and artificial
intelligence scientists are saying AI
could pose a statement released by the
center for AI safety was signed by more
than 350 people including Sam Altman
chief executive of openai and Demis
hasabis the head of Google's Deep Mind
the center for AI safety said some risks
of AI have been discussed publicly but
it wanted to open a dialogue about the
more severe risks of AI this follows
another letter released in March by Tech
leaders that called for a six-month
pause on AI work to set up industry
standards with me to discuss this latest
statement and the concerns is our AI
reporter Deepa Sita Ramen Deepa
pandemics nuclear war those certainly
are extreme risks why does this group
say a AI could reach that level what
these researchers and thinkers and
entrepreneurs are thinking through is
the current AI systems have improved so
much from what we saw even just a couple
of years ago and so they're
extrapolating and saying you know in the
future
these models could gain capabilities
that we are just not imagining yet and
they could be very risky for Humanity
broadly including potentially finding
the motivation the will and the means to
destroy people
a little scary
were they suggesting should be done this
particular statement is very sparse it's
definitely less than 25 words it's just
asking for this future risk to be taken
seriously I mean at the moment there is
this feeling that we need to think about
what the unintended consequences are for
these kinds of systems you've seen Sam
Altman and other Executives of these big
AI companies come out and seek and ask
for regulation from the US government
and others but you know at the same time
there are a lot of questions about what
the right kind of Regulation would be
the companies have one idea of it
lawmakers have another
and the other thing to remember too is
nobody actually agrees on whether or not
this is a real risk the extinction risk
right I mean is this the consensus point
of view from the AI sector no when I
talk to AI researchers people who've
been in this field for
five six seven years or longer in many
cases their feeling is that this is a
bit more of a fringe View and that there
are clear modern day risks that need to
be
really discussed and tackled so how
could AI systems be deployed in ways
that hurt already marginalized people
how do AI systems spread misinformation
about health or legal advice or politics
or whatever all right that's our AI
reporter Deepa Sita Ramen
on Tuesday chip maker Nvidia did
something few companies have ever done
it crossed the one trillion dollar
valuation Mark during intraday trading a
its shares shot up more than 24 last
week after it released a strong earnings
report and they've continued to climb
since would investors are reacting to is
the way the Boom in artificial
intelligence is translating to record
sales for NVIDIA the semiconductors it
makes are essential components to
running the complex computational
processes that are required by AI but
nvidia's rise wasn't always a sure thing
with us to talk about how the company
got here is wsj reporter ASA Fitch who
covers the chips industry so ASA a lot
of people may have heard of Nvidia after
a share price sword but can you give us
a bit of background on the company how
did it get started Nvidia started in
1993 to make computer graphics better
PCS were becoming more and more common
in households and nvidia's Pitch was
that it was going to make your graphics
crisper and make your frame rates faster
in other words make your video less
choppy and things like that it really
appealed to video Gamers to PC gamers in
particular in its early days in the 90s
so that was his bread and butter for
many many years it kind of changed
course in around 2006 when it opened up
its chips so that software developers
could Tinker with them and use them for
things other than video gaming and
people started to use them in scientific
context people started to use them in
you know in medical research and other
things like that eventually they also
started to use them in artificial
intelligence and also in cryptocurrency
mining and things like that so the
company sort of extended itself in
around the 2006-2007 era in a way that
kind of set the groundwork for where it
is today so how did Nvidia which is
still a leader in making chips for games
become so important to the AI space it
became really important in AI because of
the way these chips work effectively
when you're displaying computer Graphics
you have to calculate what each pixel is
going to look like on your screen at any
given time so you're doing a lot of
calculations simultaneously to sort that
out what's that going to look like and
that kind of computation doing a lot of
things at the same time turns out to be
something that's extremely useful when
you're doing complex Matrix math
essentially that AI requires and machine
learning requires so this kind of
computation turned out to be really well
suited to artificial intelligence let's
talk a bit about some of the challenges
that Nvidia has faced recently yeah
Nvidia has not been immune to its
challenges in its recent history I mean
some of the problems that face included
a big deal it tried to do a couple of
years ago during the pandemic it tried
to buy a chip design a company called
arm which is extremely important in the
world especially of mobile phones there
was a lot of opposition from some of
nvidia's Rivals who felt that arm might
be influenced by Nvidia not be
completely neutral with its other
customers that deal failed and that was
to some degree a setback for the company
another major challenge that Nvidia has
faced in recent years is the boom and
bust cycle around cryptocurrencies
Nvidia in addition to being a company
that's played into the AI craze also
played into the cryptocurrency craze its
chips were very good at doing the kinds
of calculations you need to mine many
popular cryptocurrencies some of the
ways in which cryptocurrencies are mined
have changed and that in itself is made
nvidia's chips less useful for those
tasks so there's a possibility that in
future crypto booms assuming one of them
happens again it won't be as affected as
it has been in the past by the
cyclicality Nvidia is certainly not the
only semiconductor maker it's certainly
not the only one who makes chips that
are used by AI developers so can you
tell us a little bit about who their
main competitors are and how those
companies are faring at the moment their
main competitors in the AI space are
essentially all of the other major chip
makers you have Advanced Micro Devices
which also makes gpus and is also
extremely big player in video gaming
they have advanced chips that work in
data centers and do AI computation like
just like in videos so they're starting
to mount more of a challenge to Nvidia
you have incumbents like Intel which has
some AI chips and AI capabilities some
significant ones actually and you have
all kinds of startups around the world
that are trying to make AI chips and you
have in addition to that big cloud
computing players like Amazon web
services and Microsoft's Azure and
Google Cloud Partners which are
themselves developing their own or have
developed their own chips that do AI
computation so there's no shortage of
competitors to Nvidia but Nvidia really
started to do this before anybody else
and so it has a pretty pretty large Head
Start I mean ASA despite the demand the
growth that Nvidia has
that demand does seem to be
apply in fact some of our colleagues
over the
wattage of chips and one of their
sources compared the hunt for chips for
AI to finding toilet paper during an
early part of the pandemic how is NVIDIA
dealing with that demand and that
shortfall well Nvidia said in its
earnings last week that it was securing
additional supplies of chips in the
second half of the year so they've tried
to get more of the chips they need to
satisfy that demand Nvidia does not
actually make its chips it outsources
their production to contract chip makers
so they're reliant on that supply chain
to deliver the chips to meet the crazy
demand that we're seeing now for for
it's just because people want to invest
in AI so they're trying to basically
just ramp up production as much as they
can that's wsj semiconductors reporter
Ace of Fitch
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories head over
to our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal thanks for listening
[Music]